Without a ribber,
knitting ribbing with knit purl stitches
on a flatbed machine
takes quite a bit of work.
You need to reform individual
stitches to create the ribbing.
Now, there's no law that says you can't
include hand knitting with your machine
knitting to obtain the look you want.
Even if you have a ribber,
sometimes it's faster and easier just
to pull out your needles,
cast on, and knit a bit of ribbing,
and hang it back on the machine,
and off you go.
The trick is to select the size
of the hand knitting needles that's
appropriate for the yarn you're using.
If you're using hand
knitting yarn, it's easy.
Just use the yarn label as a guide.
Now, if you're using cone yarn,
here's a general guideline based
on the pitch of your machine.
At first, it'll take a little bit of trial
and error, but with experience,
you'll learn what needles to use.
4.5 millimeter machines or standard gauge,
you'll probably use
a size 1 to 3 US needle.
On mid gauge machines, you'll use
somewhere between a 4 and a 6.
On 9 millimeter machines,
you'll use a US size 7 to 9.
Now, when you hang your ribbing
on the machine, you need to keep in mind
the public or the right side of both
the knitting and your garment fabric.
Some ribbing or cast on, knitting cast on,
have a right and a wrong side.
So you need to really think about
the right side of your ribbing
and which side of the garment fabric
you're going to be using for the right
side so that when you take the piece off
the machine,
you've got the public side showing.
I suggest you take a time
to try this technique.
Just knit a little ribbon on some hand
knitting needles, hang it on the machine,
and see how easy it is.
It'll probably open a wide range
of possibilities for you in using hand
knitting along with your machine knitting.